si le fue este martes escenario de
celebraciones por la aprobación de un
proyecto de ley que busca despenalizar
la interrupción del embarazo hasta las
14 semanas de gestación para que se
convierta en ley el senado deberá
aprobar el texto y conseguir el apoyo
del gobierno central un gobierno que
rechaza frontalmente al aborto
[Aplausos]
en colombia las mujeres marcharon
también exigiendo un frente a la corte
constitucional que se elimine el delito
de aborto del código penal según la
organización mesa por la vidad
346 personas fueron condenadas por
abortar entre 2006 y 2019 en el país
siendo las menores de edad las más
sancionadas las mujeres estamos
atravesadas en toda nuestra vida por
nuestras decisiones reproductivas
es muy importante para que una mujer
pueda planear estudiar participar en
política trabajar y cuidar de otros que
pueda decidir si quiere ser madre y
cuándo serlo y en qué condiciones
mientras que en el salvador las
manifestantes presionan a los
legisladores para que suavicen una de
las legislaciones antiaborto más
estrictas del mundo ésta prohíbe la
interrupción del embarazo en caso de
violación e incluso si la vida de la
madre corre peligro allí fiscales y
jueces tipifican algunos casos como un
homicidio agravado sancionado con hasta
50 años de prisión ya estamos aquí
también para solidarizarnos con todas
las mujeres que están privadas de
libertad para luchar con su justicia 20
mujeres en la actualidad están en la
cárcel debido a esta ley está receptiva
en américa latina todavía seis países
sancionan todo tipo de práctica abortiva